it is day seven of the heat wave
scorching a large part of North America
and temperatures are not letting up this
morning more than 50 million Americans
are under heat advisories and warnings
cities from the Midwest to the Northeast
will see the mercury rise into the 90s
today at least 21 people have died in
North America 18 of them in the Canadian
province of Quebec Jericka Duncan is in
Brooklyn New York where people are
hoping relief comes soon shreeka good
morning good morning where I'm standing
temperatures are expected to reach near
90 degrees much like yesterday on the
fourth of July and that hot weather
though didn't stop people from coming
out and celebrating the holiday behind
me here in Manhattan and all across the
country the blistering heat and humidity
didn't let up after sunset as hundreds
of thousands gathered at the National
Mall in Washington DC for fireworks
just hours earlier at the peak of the
heat thousands flocked to New York's
Coney Island for the annual Nathan's
Famous hot dog eating contest
bring the heat I'm ready for it I'm
ready at the annual fourth of July
parade in Bristol Rhode Island multiple
marchers were taken off the route to be
treated for heat exhaustion and to
Minneapolis organizers downgraded a July
4th half marathon from 13 miles to just
three because of the extreme weather we
have to have the safety of the runners
in mind first and foremost beaches were
packed this people looked for ways to
stay cool it's hot it's very hot Yolanda
Bessie G and her family came to New York
from North Carolina for the holiday I
came here and it's even hotter here
we're here at the pool to cool off a
little bit today and there is some good
news on the horizon temperatures are
expected to drop about 10 degrees by
tomorrow afternoon Anthony whoo that
sounds good Jericka thanks